The MCU rumor mill has indeed been working
overtime, most recently churning out the unconfirmed
report that a new film featuring a certain
Quantum Realm explorer and his crew may be
in the works.
We're referring, of course, to the pint-sized
Avenger Scott Lang, AKA Ant-Man.
Now, a new rumor has surfaced one which suggests
that the flick, if it happens, might herald
the debut of the MCU's Young Avengers.
"You want a juice box and some string cheese?"
“...Do you really have that?"
All jokes aside, most Marvel fans are already
well aware that Ant-Man's MCU status has been
a bit up in the air not because Lang and his
paramour-slash-partner the Wasp didn't make
it through the showdown with Thanos featured
in Avengers: Endgame, but because a new Ant-Man
film was conspicuously left out of Marvel's
mammoth Hall H panel at San Diego Comic-Con
2019.
With Ant-Man's absence on the Phase 4 timeline,
many fans were left wondering what would become
of the quippiest of Avengers.
To date, Marvel has yet to confirm the fate
of the Ant-Man franchise, spawning rumors
that the studio may either be planning to
take the Ant-Man and the Wasp team to the
small-screen via the Disney+ streaming platform,
or that it might not be planning to move forward
with a new Ant-Man tale at all, and that Scott
Lang's quantum realm-jumping days in the MCU
may actually be over.
Those fears appeared to be put to rest when
self-proclaimed Marvel Studios insider Charles
Murphy claimed that Ant-Man 3 is now in the
works, and that the film may be slotting into
Phase 5 of the MCU with a July 29, 2022 release
date.
Part of the reported scoop involves the discovery
of a new company being formed in California
in September 2019, with a seemingly telling
name: Pym Particles Production III LLC.
Furthermore, Murphy reported that Paul Rudd
and Evangeline Lilly would be reprising their
roles as the insect-themed, crime-fighting
duo, with Michael Douglas and Michelle Pfeiffer
presumably returning as Dr. Hank Pym and O.G.
Wasp Janet Van Dyne.
Now would be a good time to reiterate that
Marvel has not yet confirmed that Ant-Man
3 is a go for the MCU's Phase 5 or beyond
or that the film is even a possibility so
take this rumor with a big ol' grain of salt.
Mr. Murphy has produced accurate info on occasion,
but he hasn't been right about everything
and you know what they say about broken clocks.
Murphy went on to offer another whopper regarding
the possible narrative arc of Ant-Man 3, involving
Scott Lang's now teen-aged daughter Cassie.
The latest bit of MCU conjecture involves
Cassie Lang following in the footsteps of
her incredible shrinking daddy, and donning
her own shrinking suit to fight crime an arc
that would then open the door for Marvel's
Young Avengers to make their first appearance
in the MCU.
Needless to say, any storyline involving a
Young Avengers team would be a legit bombshell
for the ever-expanding MCU, and it would not
be all that surprising to see Marvel Studios
head in that direction..
If we're being completely honest, after a
decade-plus of Iron Man, Captain America,
Thor, Black Widow, and Hulk essentially leading
the charge, a little new blood would be welcome
and with several of those characters' storylines
either completed or very up in the air after
Endgame, it's clear that a few fresh faces
will be needed to take the heroic reins for
future Avengers movies.
Other than Cassie Lang and Harley Keener,
the kid from Iron Man 3 who turned up at Tony
Stark's funeral in Endgame, and who has been
speculated to be on the path to becoming the
MCU's version of Iron Lad there are a few
other canonical team members who have been
teased, officially or otherwise.
We know that Kate Bishop will indeed play
a key role in the upcoming Disney+ series
Hawkeye, with Hailee Steinfeld circling the
project.
It's also been rumored that Wiccan could play
a part in the Scarlet Witch series WandaVision,
and that Hulkling might potentially be turning
up in Captain Marvel 2.
But of course, until we get any kind of official
announcements, it's all just shiny conjecture.
At this point, we're going to have to go ahead
and call the Ant-Man 3/Young Avengers rumor
highly questionable, if only for the fact
that we don't even have confirmation on Lang's
third solo outing yet.
If we do, and if that confirmation also happens
to spawn one the biggest narrative shifts
in the MCU, then so much the better.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.